I think the shininess of Conor being
back and the fact that we know he's
going to fight Chandler we have a pretty
good idea it's going to be it's on the
horizon I think that alone has
has uh has enticed me enough to find it
interesting and I will tell you what I
do like the format of prospects versus
veterans that I actually I think they
nailed that oh you and I disagree on
this
London
I think last time I spoke to was in
person he came on food truck Diaries and
you did you didn't do the commentating
gig yet and I was vying for it I'm like
we gotta get going here UFC what are we
doing and they listened I like to take
credit for it but I had nothing to do
with it if anything I probably hurt your
career
I think I think you were the straw that
broke the camel's back I really do they
saw that that food truck Diaries and
they they saw my desire they saw your
approval your stamp of approval were
like obviously yeah Dana was like Job
gay with the green light all right let's
get around put her in put her in sign it
pick her up
um so yeah it's like it's like you know
you're just you're just doing the damn
thing you know and I think most people
expected this but it has to feel good
right to get that validation and here
and I see you being involved even more
cards obviously the contender series The
Dana White Contender says you're doing
and that's kind of where you got your
start with UFC but so that's expected
and that show's big but now you're
involved even The Ultimate Fighter the
post show which uh we're fans of hair
and I'll start there with it with the
ultimate fighter yeah
um were you a fan of Ultimate Fighter
before doing this post show I mean
obviously you're in the business but
were you like a die-hard fan Ultimate
Fighter I was a die-hard fan of the
ultimate fighter in the beginning yeah
like early days of The Ultimate Fighter
it's big it's a big part of the reason
between that and pride that's what got
me into him same same same
however there was definitely a lull in
my interest
over I would say the most recent you
know and I think that's fair to say I
think even Dana but yeah it was bad bro
like it just it was tough you know and
when they went behind the paywall it was
tough in fact it was tough yeah legit
tough like t-o-u-g-h tough not
t-u-f-tuff that show is tough to watch
and stars when stars weren't coming out
of it
um and then now it kind of piqued my
interest and obviously the general fans
interest because you have Conor involved
um I it's weird because I I wanna right
it gave me it was my ticket to the
Chocolate Factory like Ultimate Fighter
I'm an alumni it's dear to my heart or
the finalists on there it gave me
everything I have in my life now so I
ride and die for the UFC I bleed UFC I
bleed the ultimate fighter I was so
excited to watch it and I don't you ever
like have a favorite movie like when
you're a kid and then you go back and
watch you tell like your friend or your
girlfriend whatever you're like you guys
see this movie it's so good like oh it
doesn't hold up and that's it's not that
the all Ultimate Fighter is a bad
product very well done but it it I'm
starting to think it's like oh does this
does this kind of the way it's organized
the way it's going down like has has
have we moved on from this you know is
it that or I it was missing something
now the second episode got me kind of
back into I thought the second one was
better I don't know what it is if the
format just doesn't work on regular TV
now I don't know what it is but it
listen I'm going to generate I'll watch
it all
yeah you know I think um your analogy is
perfect it really hits home because I'm
in the this phase of trying to introduce
my son to like movies from the 80s and
90s that I really thought were amazing
but that are still and they're adult but
like like still okay for a kid his age
to watch Kindergarten Cop for instance
in my mind this is like oscar-worthy
acting
yeah hell yeah I love that movie it is
it is a good movie but you realize how
corny a lot of the 90s movies in
particular were but I digress
um with insert in terms of tough yeah
like I
I think the shininess of Conor being
back and the fact that we know he's
gonna fight Chandler we have a pretty
good idea it's going to be it's on the
horizon I think that alone has
has uh has enticed me enough to find it
interesting and I will tell you what I
do like the format of prospects versus
veterans that I actually I think they
nailed that oh you and I didn't disagree
on this it's really it's it's my biggest
issue with the show now listen this has
come from a guy who is a prospect and
had to fight a veteran and lost in the
finale to a veteran when I signed up for
that show the game the what I was told
is it's guys who are I've tried other
guys like me yes and then Roy Nelson
there who you know I'm a fan of mixed
martial arts I'm like well he's he's a
form world champion I just saw him fight
Ben Rothwell I have three fights what
are we doing here and then obviously I
ended up fighting him in the finale so
maybe it's that with me but also just
get look at the way the fights are going
down like when I saw Prospect veterans
I'm like oh that's a terrible idea
because
that atmosphere for a young prospect
it's it's a lot for a veteran it's like
there's no fans this this oh this
there's not that much pressure and then
you see how the fights are going these
veterans are starching these young dudes
yeah like last night's episode I'm like
oh that kid's screwed that poor kid that
they're they're just getting annihilated
I know first you get run through by a 17
year old and then you know yeah like
it's a tough go man getting these but
here's what here's why I like it here's
why I like it because and I think it's
maybe just you know your perspective is
unique to your experience I think I have
a real soft spot for the guys who it's
like they were so they were so close or
they were there and they were just so
close to like really hitting their
stride in the UFC and for whatever
reason it didn't pan out I love the
underdog I think that's what I what I
like about it but let me ask you this
you know put your mark and hat on to
take out your love for The Ultimate
Fighter take out you how you work for
the UFC let's say we're in a marking
meeting there's not the left right I
know yeah me neither yes I got nothing
but so if you know Hollywood meeting
room
and and they're in the Dana White Center
and Dana doesn't know there's no
relationship
and if they brought that to me I'd say
hold on you tell me these guys have
already fought in UFC and they were
correct and I go and it didn't go well
for him they would know okay so then
they're going to fight easier
competition probably do well because
they're more experienced the chance of a
veteran winning the show is pretty high
so if that veteran wins and he's already
failed in the UFC what's the plan with
him you're telling me he's gonna compete
with the top 15
who do we get we give them more
prospects to take out like what do we do
with the guy yeah what like what do you
do like they're not going to compete
with these Top Dogs on the flip side of
that you know if you look at it through
the other side of that exact same lens
you know you've got a lot of guys coming
off of contender Series in particular
where on that show you only have to have
one match up to make it into the UFC and
you might get a really favorable matchup
where you might get a really unfavorable
matchup it's really kind of I don't know
it's a rule the dice on that show much
more so than it is for the ultimate
fighter because you've got a little bit
longer to sort of prove yourself build
your brand all that type of stuff so
while on one hand you're like okay but
he already proved that it's it's not
going to pan out yeah from the prospects
how are they going to pan out if they
can't get through this series of
veterans if they can't get through these
guys then how are they going to fare in
the UFC so it kind of it to me it works
but it works both ways and regardless
the cream is going to rise to the to the
top I think whether it's a vet or
whether it's a prospect but I do agree
with you that there's an inherent
Advantage for the Vets now we don't know
yet what we have in terms of prospects
you know this uh the guy that Conor
keeps talking about Lee true we may have
some real Superstars we just haven't
seen yet there might be some Prospect
who can just annihilate these veterans
and data's like shut them out that's why
we did this but then also exactly when
Connor picked uh you know the the uh
kind of the prospects because there's
one guy's on the team it's like God that
was a mistake and then also can we blend
them does it have to be all prospects
all veterans can we blend it so it's
more favorable because I mean Carl might
have that one guy and yeah he might do
his thing but the red you know it's
gonna be tough on the rest of the guys
yeah I don't know that's I mean again I
like the show and you know but it does
seem like Chandler you know made the
Smart Pick I feel like Chandler he's a
little more invested in it as far as
like you see the coaching
um he kind of zoned out when the guy was
sharing his adoption story whatever I
love Chandler he did not yeah he did
that kid was like that kid was like that
kid was like Hey and you can see it was
like kind of set up he's like they're
like leaving practice you know Chandler
has two adopt the kids he's like hey man
I was adopting Channel like oh cool
where are you from he's all what uh
Chicago is like right on man God puts
all sorts of families together like kept
going the kid's like Oh I thought this
was gonna be like my story
um yeah just kidding Chandler knows I
love him but he was like yeah very cool
uh anyways so you're adopted no but um
yeah I just and the other the other
caveat and I had Chandler on earlier and
he's like yeah we shot this in four
weeks yes and be an ultimate fight I'm
like oh my God that is yes so fast yes
aren't they normally like 12. uh I know
they they've done a 12 Weeks live was
12. because I was listening to kiasa
talk yes live was 12. mine was uh it by
the time you get through seven weeks I
think they filmed six but you're there
from six to eight weeks but four is
flying now for the guys making weight
you know it probably helps in advance
because I guess they're fighting a
little sooner so they can kind of
control that weight but Man flying in
four weeks is nuts and also as far as
like the team Vibe goes in four weeks
anyway guys are losing it's you know so
the whole team aspect of it I don't know
but again I do like it
yeah it's tough to it's tough to gel and
then in that amount of time for sure but
I'm you know I think to some degree if
you're gonna have Conor McGregor on a
show you're gonna have to you you know
he can't live in Vegas for 13 weeks
straight with his that's a fair point
too I mean he doesn't come to the way he
hasn't been away in yet
yeah you know and I meant to I'm going
to ask John about that next week when we
do our little uh sit down our little
react thing that we do
um because you know I'm sure there's I'm
sure there's reasonings and I'm sure it
has to do with how busy of an individual
he is and also like I think I think one
thing you got to keep in mind and I
thought it was really interesting the
way Connor came out the gate not only
with like getting his guys to spar right
off of the bat but like he himself
stepping in there
a lot of the show for me is Conor not
just proving or not just showing that
like oh I can be a good coach and these
are my guys but like
proving where he's at in terms of being
ready to fight again agree that's a big
part of it I think that that's why a lot
of people are tuning in
um I do think and did you watch the
counter doc do you like documentary I
did yeah I did still waiting for my
check from being featured on that
whatever but um Conor that doc without
and I'm a bit the biggest Conor fan like
me and Casey my producer we love Connor
like he's one of the reasons you know my
show popped when it did I'm the biggest
Conor fan I worked the Conor fight for
Showtime that's how I got him with
Showtime so I owe a lot of my career to
Conor huge Conor dick rider here going
to be completely transparent but I think
part of you know when you watch the
documentary and I think even The
Ultimate Fighter house like he's just a
special person he just realized like
even when he went and visited the kids
on last night's episode you can just see
like they're they're just the the energy
in the room and he leaves and they're
like oh my God that guy is electric he's
just he's something we've never seen
before and I think the doc did a good
job because remember that doc wasn't
like a happy story
like the first episode shows like it's
come up and he's 14 and all that stuff
but the majority of that Doc is you know
I think he loses the three it's his
three biggest fights that he loses so
it's not like a happy thing but I think
the takeaway from that which a that
documentary made me sad because I don't
think we'll ever see another Conor
McGregor so I got really sad but then
also uh B I think it made people realize
like he's this outlier like he's our
Kobe Bryant like he has that Mom Mamba
mentality like he wants it so bad he
went and like he works his ass off
because it's like for my mom or my
brother who aren't you know in the game
like we are they just see the Conor
Antics and then they'll see his
pay-per-view and he's like oh this guy's
crazy it's like no no no no that
craziness is what makes him special I
think that's kind of coming over the
ultimate fighter yeah no I the the
passion that he has for the sport is
apparent because he the reality is he
didn't need to do this show you know
like it's not like he needs a bigger
profile and it certainly even though I'm
sure they condensed it partly for him
even four weeks that's kind of a pain
for him to not be able to do life the
way that he wants to do it right and
show up and have all these obligations
and media obligations you got to be here
and you got to film at this time like
I'm sure that that's not his ideal way
to spend his time but the passion that
he has for the sport and therefore the
guys that are on the come up is evident
to me and I asked uh John Kavanaugh I
said you know is that is that magnetism
that we see
is that something that came along with
the spotlight and he said no no he had
that the moment the moment it was maybe
a little bit different but like I think
they met when when Connor was 17 and he
said he he had that the day I met him
it's grown and it's matured and whatnot
but he's definitely an individual who's
got something that you can't buy and
something that you can't train or or
something that you can't try for either
have it or you don't I agree and I I
think to your point too before you start
talking about tough you're saying one of
the kind of interesting things is we're
all waiting for the announcement of
Conor versus Chandler
and I can't wait
my only kind of hang up with that is
Dana was in a press conference recently
and goes like when's Conor and uh
Chandler going to find he goes it's
tough to Wrangle these guys in man you
know like they have so much money it's
tough to get these guys in and I was
like oh what do you mean I thought he
wrangled him in what well are we not
getting this you know so it's like are
they dangling they care I'm like no he's
gonna fight and then it doesn't happen
because I hear Dana say that I'm like
what do you mean it's tough to Wrangle
them in now part of me being such a big
Connor fan goes dope he's sad don't have
to fight ever again he's good for my
business he's just I'd love to watch him
fight so I hope he fights if he doesn't
that's a good thing like he's so
financially set he's made so many smart
decisions he's earned it right off of
the sunset on your Lamborghini yacht but
this this Ultimate Fighter is gonna be
sad if we don't get that fight
I think we will I don't I mean I I do I
I think that we will I think there's
something about and I can't even put my
finger on what it is but there's
something about Conor that
he just he's gonna refuse to go out the
way you know with a broken leg going out
of the Octagon on a gurney that's just
not how he's gonna leave the sport so I
I have high hopes you know I have no
Insider knowledge about it but I have I
have high hopes and
what's up
I'm with you me too yeah please fight
um and what your boy uh John Kavanaugh
who's Connor's head coach house has has
he told you like his takeaway from you
know being in the house gets a lot in
the coaches too and him being the head
coach he does most of the work like
Conor's there but really John's
designing the training program putting
the kids through it he's coming up with
the game plans he's spent a little more
time with him you know Conor's doing his
thing but it falls a lot on John people
don't realize how much work it is for
the coaches yeah a ton of work and I he
actually asked to do it because I guess
that he
that he took so many obligations with
other Fighters that he he decided it
wasn't he just couldn't dedicate that
much time to being in the United States
you know it's different for those guys
too to be not just away from their
normal gym but like out of the country
completely so
um he he made a point to do this season
he felt like it was kind of a bucket
list thing for him and I you know I
think his biggest takeaway is just how
how passionate and how all in on this
sport Connor is despite having
everything he could have ever dreamed of
imagined and wanted and and he did say
something I thought was interesting he
said you know I haven't really seen him
in person tons because we we hadn't
really yet started like fully ramping up
training so he said this you know when
you see that scene of him sparring it
was one of the first times I'd seen him
work out in quite a while and so I think
I think part of that scene was like kind
of proving to coach Kavanaugh like hey
I'm I'm good like we're good to go we're
ready to hit the hit the ground running
and you know get this Camp going yeah
that's good that's another reason why I
feel really optimistic about a fight
being on the horizon as well me too it'd
be a shame if it doesn't work down I
doubt Conor would do that to the fan
base you know and just get everybody
excited and just delay it that's not
usually his style now this can be a
tough question for you being obviously
you know Dana White contingencies close
to your heart your big you know reason
that things is Success now you're
involved The Ultimate Fighter if you're
a manager of a fighter young fighter and
you have an author to do the next
Ultimate Fighter knowing how the ratings
are going right you know the ratings are
they are what they are you know it's
tough so you have the ultimate fighter
and you have Dan White Contender Series
where you going where are you having and
your Fighter's like ah I'm trying to
decide they said I can do either one
which road you send them down I mean I'm
going to pick Contender series every
time personally because
I think the I mean you know the ultimate
fighter is a whole different animal and
if you're not
you're not geared mentally to deal with
the all of the extra pressure of being
away from your family and your gym and
cutting weight multiple times in a very
short period of time and you know
getting to be good friends with your
with a guy and then all of a sudden
you're fighting like there are so many X
factors in that show that make it I
think even more difficult than Contender
series Contender series is a fight and
there's trust me there's pressure Dana
White's sitting right there and there is
kind of what I said earlier about like
you got this one shot and this one match
up to make an impression but I I'm still
gonna go Contender series and I think
that show more and more and more is
really churning out top tier talent and
they when you go on that show and you do
big things like there's now a formula
right like we see it every year now the
guys that stand out every year get a
huge push their UFC debuts and if they
do well there you know the Joe pifers of
the world yeah yeah Off to the Races
agree and yeah and you know I'm curious
if because because Connor's ratings are
this and they're not bad don't get me
wrong they're not bad but it's not
gangbusters but also there's just so
much more content out than what say
season 10 which is the biggest season of
all time not a big deal but when season
10 was just at different times on Spike
during this but there wasn't as much
competition so I think the numbers are
solid I'm sure ESPN's happy with it I'm
curious if this if we're going to get an
announcement of the you know more
ultimate fighters on ESPN Not ESPN plus
and you know Fight Pass but actual ESPN
I'm wondering what how ESPN feels about
it what what year would have would
season 10 have been what year was that
uh that would have been 2018
um that would have been 2013. yeah so I
think 10 years it seems like just the
cultural appetite for reality television
in general has kind of changed
um so I don't and I don't know that
we're gonna see that fully shift back I
you know I think it'd be cool to do
something like The Ultimate Fighter but
maybe shake up the format a little bit I
have no idea what that looks like don't
ask me if I have a good idea about that
I agree agree
um well yeah I mean I'm a huge fan
ultimate fire and I hope it just keeps
doing great things I hope to for to
prove me wrong I hope one of those uh
prospects goes out and does some big
things because then yes completely
annihilates my argument and that and
then the UFC's my GAP shops are wrong
again so they might be right
2009 was uh Ultimate Fighter 10 I'm way
off yeah so Peak Peak yeah that was like
Paris Hilton on reality TV real world's
popping I'm on there I I think I like it
I like to credit myself I think it was
the Kimbo Slice effect
he was massive massive back then uh when
we can't let you leave without talking
about UFC 289 it's going down on
Saturday excited for it I am excited for
it I think we've got the fight that we
that we wanted to see in Amanda Nunes
versus Irene aldana I mean over the Pena
you're saying uh yeah I think so I mean
for me for me personally and I I love I
really like the match-up in terms of I
think it's even though Amanda Nunes has
way more ways to win on paper she's so
much I would say more dangerous in every
aspect of the game Iranian aldana has a
particular style of boxing that Amanda
has not hasn't had to deal with yet even
when she faced Holly Holm Holly Holm one
of the most decorated boxers ever but
the way that Holly fights in MMA
different yeah is totally different like
she's a kickboxer she floats on the
outside a Radio Donna is gonna get right
in your face with clean straight shots a
nice you know super educated guard that
she stays super safe with and you know
you watch the Pena fight the first one
some of the stuff that Amanda struggled
with was even outside of all of the X
factors that I think did contribute to
that loss some of the things that she
struggled with was pressure and straight
shots and that's what you get when you
get a Randy aldana who also has
phenomenal takedown defense so it's
although Irani doesn't have like this
amazing undefeated record that we can
like point at and get all frothy about
no not at all a skill set I can
definitely get excited about she does
and on Monday when I did the shop show I
actually I actually picked uh Albania
and then as I sit on it I do more
research because I go do this breakdown
tomorrow for that show for that fight
I don't know man like you look at it and
you're like well hold up if it's Amanda
Nunez that showed up against Pena too
there's no way in hell she's gonna how's
she gonna beat her it's tough to find a
route for her to win and especially if
Amanda Nunez where you know she makes it
up on Penny 2 when she went to South
Paul gave her a ton of problems or check
hooks filthy and we know aldana
struggles southpaws well penny is I mean
Amanda knew that's pretty damn good at
Southpaw
that is good you know how Dana has the
boxing Advantage but Amanda man she does
everything well there's a reason why
she's the greatest of all time I think
we're all predicating this like when
people are picking out Dana there's also
the Mexican Factor right Mexican are
taking over the what three chance we
include the interim champ yeah um so
they're doing the damn thing so I think
it's the cool pick and I actually
retract my pick because if Amanda shows
up that was the man of news in the
second fight I don't see it I just don't
see it and because we're all predicated
on Amanda's over it she doesn't want to
do it anymore she has I think a second
baby or she have the second baby already
you know on the way in November I think
there you go so the baby's coming so
she's busy with that you know she's one
foot in one foot out yeah if that Amanda
shows up the first fight that when she
fought Pena yeah she's probably gonna
lose but man you better pray to God if
you're a fan of Aldina that uh that that
does happen because if not she's gonna
get she can have a long night in the
office and by a long time
the South Pole thing could be a real a
real problem because we did see El
Donald struggle a little bit with that
both with Macy chasson and um a few
others and I will say this there's you
know there are really not that many
female fighters who are true switch
dancers and do it fluidly yes and who
are as offensively and defensively sound
out of both dances so it's not something
that women deal with a lot in the
training room or in fights and so when
you put someone with Amanda's skill set
already and then you add a new tool like
that
I mean that's it's gonna be it's going
to be an uphill battle and it's funny
that you say that because literally what
you just said is is kind of where I've
been on it I was very excited about all
Donna at first I'm like oh her pressure
her boxing her power her size her
athleticism there's lots to talk about
but then you go watch
you could watch that panty two fighting
and you're like oh I don't know like uh
yeah that's where I was I picked on
Monday and then again I do this
breakdown tomorrow I'm watching tape I'm
like oh this is not a good matchup if if
it's the Amanda Nunez that wants this
she can do whatever she wants you know
but you gotta you know who knows what
we're gonna get the I'm excited for that
by doing me wrong but I think the most
exciting find the card is Darius Charles
Oliveira
100 100
and the fight that fight saved the card
let's be honest it does and it's the
fight that should have happened a long
time ago it's probably the fight that
should have had a belt involved with it
but I'm still happy it's happening I'll
take it um and I yeah what I I'll get
you I want your take on this I think
it's really interesting that like not
that long ago we were when we were
talking about Charles Charles Oliveira
we as analysts started using all these
superlatives like you know one of the
greatest lightweights of all time you uh
you know the best of this the best that
of course statistically he is the best
finisher the best submission
but I feel like that one loss has really
diminished his shine and I don't
understand why because like gaichi loses
to Habib you don't really feel the same
lack of shine with gaichi like oh it's
still gay she lost a Habib no big deal
but then you got trolls over there who
loses to Islam and it's like ah but Izzy
is really I'm saying it it's just a
feeling I have and I don't even know how
to put my fingers me neither I was I've
seen this on my show on Monday I don't
know what it is I and I apologize to
Charles Oliveira I never pick him he won
like 10 11 fights I picked against him
every single time this fight picking
against him I I apologize I don't know
what it is I have no clue why I do this
to you I like Brazilians so my favorite
people I never picked this guy I don't
I'm not picking him in this fight and
you look at the stats and then for a
while with Charles because he's been
doing it forever he has so many fights
remember there were some fights where he
quit and I maybe again maybe it's my own
personal thing but when a guy quits I'm
I'm out I'm out but somehow he's one of
the rare rare exceptions where he did
have that quit in him and he figured it
out and that's no longer in there
because he could have quit against
Chandler he could have quit against all
these other guys and he finds a way to
figure it out even then and I see it so
I don't call him a quitter anymore
that's not nice but I just I pick
against the guy and he's one of the
greatest to ever do it but again Darius
I just I look at that fight I go hey I I
think Darius deserves it to get a Top
Shot if he wins this for sure deserves
it being a guy you know who was the
reigning champ for so long if you were
to get it finished you have to give him
a title shots his ninth fight win in a
row but with Darius I think where he's
different is if you look at Charles
Oliveira he will get hit he'll get hit
and the trailer fight gets hit and guys
are scared to follow that up because
they're scared of his Jujitsu Darius is
not scared of his Jujitsu Darius you
know compete against Chrome Gracie and
straight gay Jiu Jitsu like world
champion Jitsu player phenomenal Jiu
Jitsu practitioner he's not gonna be
scared to go down there's nothing that
Charles Oliveira offers down there that
douche hasn't seen before so he'll
follow it up and get the finish and I
and I could see him not only get a
finish via TKO but I could see him uh
submitting him with like a rare naked
down there or something 100 and it's
also that the threat of the uh
submission game is also what has made
Charles A striking game
you know because any any threat of a
takedown any threat of a back take
anything of a snap down grab the neck
guys are always having to think about
that other thing and you know
benildarius just isn't going to have to
do that and all I mean I'm not the only
one saying this I I think vanilla de
ryush has a better
grappling game or MMA then Charles
Olivera does which I realize sounds
ridiculous it doesn't you're 100 you're
100 on the ball with that he has a
better graphic game for the four mixed
martial arts and it's also his
fundamentals I think are better now
who's more dangerous probably Charles
Oliver as far as like in transition with
the darses and The Guillotines and you
know the Army opportunistic correct but
as far when it comes down to like the
fundamentals and like the the the the
the technical aspect of it Darius all
day I just trained dare you she's a he's
a nightmare monster so yeah I'm picking
Darius and I apologize Charles Olivera I
picked this 11th fight 10 years in a
ride pick against the guy I don't know
why I couldn't tell you why Daniel ever
fooled you up
no no no don't get crazy don't you come
on come on come on come on come on no
I'm I'm 400 pounds come on I know I know
no it's rarely Road uh rolled together
we're at uh Black cast together but just
the nicest guy like he's for sure
getting to Heaven before me you know
like he's so close with Jesus Christ I
think it works like that
I tell myself
what I am but I just know that he he is
uh Jesus's cell phone and I don't you
know so yeah definitely need to have it
before me uh besides that I mean this
UFC is good but
you know there's two really good fights
on the rest of them are good fights
nothing will knock your hair back but
then after this it's gangbusters like
UFC's dropping pay-per-view pay-per-view
pay-per-view I can't wait for it this
late summer fall even into the winter I
mean the rest the rest of 22 23 is going
to be bananas absolutely bananas do you
think we get
um Jones verstepe
I think we get Jones versus somebody I
don't I'm not feeling uh again I was I
always had to hesitate to say this
because people like oh maybe she knows
something I don't know anything but
um
I don't know I feel like I feel like for
a second there people started being like
Oh pavlovich is great pavlovich is great
you know which to me always indicates
that maybe there's uh I don't know yeah
well I think the rumor started I'll take
credit for well Chael sonen should take
credit first that was you it was me and
chale but it was jail breaking the news
and you know you know jails boys with
everybody in the UFC so he was like the
the steepe fights not getting done it's
gonna be published in August and I was
like what and so he broke that news on
here but then shortly after that I get a
text from him and a guy very close to
John going no no Stevie actually signed
the the deal it's happening oh so I
think Steve and John is going to happen
in November Madison Square Garden
well I love that we'll see love that
we'll see I think I'm more
confident in Stipe and John fighting
than Connor and Chandler to be honest
this year this year I'm not I'm not um
I'm not
we should make a little little friendly
wager on it we should I think we get
both I'm just I think I mean John has to
fight Steve has fight I think there's
someone into it too a steep base
contract thinking only had one fight on
his contract he's waiting to see what
happened with the Francis stuff he could
have went over to pfl I think there's a
lot going on there
do you think John if John beats Stipe do
you think he retires
that's a good question yes
what is he gonna do hang around for the
winner of Almeida and Curtis blades yeah
I like you like what's Pavlich like
let's say he waits for Pavlich which
sells I don't know 100 000 pay-per-views
and the guys is dangerous he has no
brand value terrifying he he you know
what he is he's the jokic of the UFC
yeah he's probably the best heavyweight
not named Jon Jones hits like a Mack
truck not an ounce of fat on him this
Russian Destroyer Americans aren't
familiar with him he's like Joe kids I
don't know if you watch basketball my
Denver Nugget is playing tonight but
he's like jokic he's the MVP of the
league he's the best player he's tough
to Market tough to Market but he's so
damn good that's like Pavlich it's like
this guy is a nightmare man yeah and for
John he's like why what do I have to
prove exactly
that'd be a bummer if he retires because
let's say you get Jones retires after
that and then let's say heaven forbade
Conor loses he retires
I I I'm they're going to force me to
retire who what am I going to cover who
are we going to cover you know I know
what we're going to do we're gonna have
to start a cooking show or something
yeah yeah for reals you gotta hope sugar
Shawn comes along and he's the next
Conor with the rainbow hair for sure I
don't know for sure but I'm excited I
appreciate you doing this really do
last thing last thing because I don't
get it to verbally uh spar with anybody
it's just me by myself ranting the
camera so I feel like I have the best
ideas what would you do to change MMA
judging clearly a problem clearly we
have a problem and people just go you
can't leave in the hands of the judges
that doesn't work for me all these
people are good like people don't
realize that when you say just you can't
even hand the judges you don't
understand like how good volkanovsky and
Mark Chev are you have at that level the
the top
I'll say top 50 in some weight classes
they're so damn good it's you can't say
that those guys are so damn tough to get
out of there so we have to fix the
judging but you know I don't know what
what you do
well there's two things there's an
immediate a more immediate solution and
there's a long-term solution the
long-term solution is to to continue to
tweak and perfect the criteria because I
do think that there are some
things about the criteria that could be
made better especially if you got more
Fighters involved with writing them but
that is a really tough thing to change
because you got 50 different cats going
50 different directions with all sorts
of different you know we don't want to
do it we it's really tough to get 50
different commissions to move at once
even it's hard to get the top five to
all be on the same page about stuff so
say we sh we shelf that
I think that's the best idea though it's
hate to interrupt you that's the best
idea because the curriculum that they
have to judge off of is all messed up so
just starting there the way they judge
fights is an issue but carry on yeah and
here's here's the real thing anytime
take MMA out of it anytime you want to
get more accurate results mathematically
you have to make the numbers bigger
if you're talking about averages if
you're talking about means medians I
mean we've all taken I'm guessing we've
all taken some amount of basic
statistics the not the sample size has
to be bigger so imagine if you go from
three judges to five judges imagine if
you go from five judges to seven judges
imagine if you've got you know five
judges on site and another seven judges
in a quiet Booth off-site somewhere now
I understand as you get bigger and
bigger
this is what I said but like more judges
and then more judges but and you've been
cage side it's impossible to see what's
kind of going on in the grand scheme of
things I don't care who you are even for
me a trained eye been a million gyms
been a million fights it's it's like ah
what's going on there it's and then I go
score it now if they had the same access
that we have on TV and they're in a
remote location in Vegas somewhere no
they're not swayed by the audience
they're not swayed by the commentating
they're watching in silence on their own
in their own room dark room you know and
you give them food but whatever and
water dark room yeah
we waterboard them if they get it wrong
no but
yeah yeah oh yeah they're naked wait
what no but I do think that there has to
be something to that more judges and not
just going based off the ringside
judging that's insane
and here's the one thing that people
often forget about it's not just like
everybody wants to say oh we've got
terrible judges I just I'm sorry like
that's a lazy thing to say agree it
really is I'm not saying it doesn't
exist at all I do think there's been
some poor judging that we can point to
but as a generality I disagree with it
as a generality I I just disagree with
that I think it's a lazy thing that we
have a tendency to say
I think a lot of things that people
forget about so in for instance one
judge sits on the side of the Octagon
where the door is okay you're then
talking about four turnbuckles they
can't get up and walk around no now they
have a screen which frankly most of the
time when we've been like oh these
judges are looking at their phones
they're not looking at their phones
they're looking at their monitors
because they can't see what's happening
as someone who calls these fights
sometimes I don't say things because I'm
like I'm not really sure what's
happening right now because I don't my
angle both in my reality view as well as
what's being shown to me on the camera
is not enough for me to understand if
there's a submission happening or not
now imagine if you had to say something
because that's your job like the judges
where they have to score it you have to
say something people are like Laura's
way off man
you cannot judge what you cannot see
that's how they're taught like if you
don't see it you can't assume that
something is there so there's all these
little things that I think the general
public doesn't always take into
consideration but to me the biggest
easiest solution is more judges you make
the numbers bigger then you make the
results more accurate that's just math
that's it's just factual imagine a world
where one of those votes one of those
judges was actually a compilation of
trained maybe media professionals like
you have to pass a test on the criteria
you can't just be like I'm sorry but the
can the fan base cannot vote because
that becomes a popularity contest no I
can't do that it sounds cool but NBA
does the All-Star Game Yao Ming was like
the number one player to the Chinese
every year you can't you can't do that
you have to have relatively unbiased
people who are educating the criteria
but maybe you've got 50 media members
and you collect all of their votes into
one vote and that becomes one of the
judges there's a number of ways to make
the numbers much much bigger therefore
you've got you take out the outliers the
bad decision whether one way the bad
decision this way in every single round
and you end up with more accurate
results it's just that's that's how math
works I'm with you and to piggyback on
the idea let's say let's say you want
you know you want to leave it as three
judges but those aren't three individual
people so for the first judge that's the
media that's the 50 media members the
second is all former retired and retired
Fighters 50 Fighters that know what the
hell is going on that fought at the
highest level then the third one can be
whatever you decide you want to make it
but again you get a bigger sample size
of people that know have an idea what
the hell is going on and they're not
from the boxing world
yeah
yeah I mean I think more and more
um I'm trying to remember I had this
written down someplace the whole boxing
judge thing that is changing
um
predominantly they're not boxing judges
anymore that's been something that has
that has shifted over time as more and
more people have actually come up as
MMA informed individuals who actually
came into judging simply to judge MMA
there still is
expect to differ but yeah
well there's still a contingency of
boxing judges
when you sit down and you ask these you
know you ask these guys okay name name
the judges who came into MMA judging
from boxing and they'll tell you and
there's about I'm gonna say the number
wrong so I almost don't want to say it
but it's not as many as you would think
it's a low number yeah that's that's
good step in the right direction I think
the only time there's a change is when
it affects the UFC's bottom line the
Fighter's bottom line is not going to
change it has to affect the U it has to
get so bad where it affects the UFC's
bottom line where some you know say
Conor not now but in his Heyday was
going to decision they kept giving to
the other guy and you know she's like
what are we doing here man this guy
clearly money is the face of the
freaking UFC that would make a change
because they'd have to like we can't
have this happening in boxing they
obviously have a huge issue because they
want to keep the guy the face of boxing
so they score the judges his way which
is a whole another you know corrupt
system but the other biggest easiest
thing to do is is and I don't like the
term accountability because then again
it has this annotation of like you guys
are screwing up and we want to punish
you for it I just want transparency me
too like after a night like albazi
versus kaiko France and it doesn't even
have to be that specific Judge like I
understand that not everybody feels
comfortable being put on a spotlight and
grilled by the media or whoever but have
a representative just like the NBA does
a referees representative that will come
out and say hey here I had a discussion
with these judges this is exactly why it
was judges way you could even [__]
bring clips up like see this
this is what this is like I remember one
time sorry I'm making this insanely long
Brenda you can cut me off at any time
but keep going I'm very passionate about
judging um the uh the Sean O'Malley
versus Peoria on fight was a super close
one very close and I ended up talking uh
to two of those judges who scored it in
a way that a lot of people here felt
like was inaccurate they scored it for
Sean and honestly so much of it came
down to I think it was the first round
there's a takedown
where Sean or where pewter gets him
elevates him but Sean posts
and then he gets the takedown
so typically when you're scoring
takedowns they don't matter at all
unless there is elevation amplitude and
impact he got the elevation but he did
not have
impactful impact because of the way Sean
posted so it wasn't would there have to
be control too right like the same thing
with the Henry sudo uh DJ fight like
that's takedown it's like it's not in
wrestling even in wrestling where the
that the takedown originated from that
is not a that they would not count as a
takedown that's what DC had to come out
and say you know DC's Mr Wrestling was
an Olympic team and he's like I think it
was him Dominic Cruz were like arguing
over it and this was like hold up in our
sport of wrestling dude which he teaches
you know he teaches camps Olympian
Oklahoma State national champion he's
like that would not even count in our
sport let alone the UFC man in mixed
martial arts so I think the definition
of a takedown they're getting more
educated on it I can't believe you
talked one I don't think I don't know
what they look like but I think I assume
like these warlocks like but I do think
um they're both they're both brown belts
oh really yeah that's the other thing
like again I think even if they're black
belts but that's fine
white belts man they know what the
hell's going on oh really no but it does
help that at least brown belts but I
think you know there should be some
accountability whether it's a
representative like you said that's a
great idea if they're scared to talking
from a camera also don't be a judge if
you can't talk about it but then I think
you could also do the way they do like
those drug bust videos where they have
like the gang member and they like blur
out his face and he's like I scored it
for Peter yawn you know so we don't know
what they look like cross references be
sick but yeah yeah no I know what you're
saying ideas here no I love it I love it
I love it those are those are all really
really but the accountability thing
should be something because I guarantee
they would that could be done tomorrow
oh I know
like it doesn't cost anything and it
would it would build so much trust like
again this the the perceptions that we
all have are because we don't really
know and maybe they're right
but maybe they're not right and the we
just don't know I I interviewed a an NBA
referee because I was curious to see how
they handled things they have a system
for every single [__] up ever over there
and they even tweet about it like the
NBA has a Twitter uh handle for their
NBA officials I love them they messed up
a call they literally tweet out like you
know in this in this game this call was
made and that was a bad call and here's
what we're doing about it and this rough
is being you know benched for a couple
games or we don't feel like any sort of
um repercussions are necessary but it
was a you know wasn't a good call like
they just say it but and again I think
that for the fans like okay at least
they're explaining it I don't agree with
it but that's how they got there good
enough the transparency is the biggest
issue I think in MMA judging because
it's just it's their way or the highway
so that that's when you get all these
conspiracies and all this stuff it makes
it worse where if they just had to your
point of Representative you don't want a
single amount they have their own
accounts they they get more hate than I
do they get annihilated annihilated yeah
so we don't want that for them and
they're chasing after their family or
whatever but again if you just had like
MMA you know reffing Inc or whatever it
has their own platform and they would
discuss why they came to that conclusion
the transparency would help so many
people out
it would help educate people on the
criteria too you know there's there's
still a lot of people that feel like
control time or you know uh you know
octagon control is a part of what makes
a round score a certain way and it's
just not yeah I mean Donna Cruz on
combat's fight Campaign which we need to
get you on but Donna Cruz on caba's
fight command he was saying I love that
yeah it'd be so much fun but Dom was on
there and he was saying he was I sat in
and they they educated me on what their
judging goes damage is number one yeah
it's like people forget like a damage is
number one man and people don't take
that into consideration yeah and one
last Point too that I that blew my mind
because I said I was in the same class
that he took actually sat next to him it
was really funny because he was so
annoyed the whole time I bet yeah
um
the thing the thing that blew my mind I
had no idea I had never heard before not
to do with judging but sort of
interrelated the statistics the
statistics that the UFC puts up for
significant strikes
every single strike at distance is
considered significant it could be the
lightest jab the lightest distance
finding job ever it's significant I
don't know why but for whatever reason
that is how they've defined it so again
when you look at it I need to watch the
mirabazi kaikon France fight again
because I think that that might have
played a really big role because
it makes no sense to me that we count a
distance finding job as significant but
the judges are specifically no no we
only judge on damage like those those
are polar opposite things I agree so
we're showing the audience a number that
says there were X number of significant
strikes and in my mind I'm like oh
significant means that they did damage
well absolutely not yeah 100 not yeah
I'd see the kaikira France decision and
then even the Shawn O'Malley over Peter
Young decision those I don't I really
don't have any questions I'd like if
they came out and told me how they
scored it but those are so close I'm
like I can come to conclusion how they
got there no issues it's like when you
get the GSP Johnny Hendricks or uh the
Patty pimlet fight right Gordon those
are like what the hell is going on there
yeah when they're super close and nobody
got robbed yeah yeah it's tough guys I
get it I flipped out about the even
though the right person won Corey
sandhagen versus Chino Vera the fact
that a judge gave Cheeto Vera that fight
was
ludicrous ludicrous
to that there's background that judge
had judged three fights three fights at
that level before being put in a main
event in Kansas City well you're ready
for this that's the stuff that should
not happen get ready for this this
definitely should happen so Corey said
hey and good buddy of mine I've known
quite since he was 15. Kim we're from
the same Hometown known forever he comes
on food truck uh right after that yeah
and I and he goes you want to hear about
that judge and he said I think on The
Ultimate Fighter uh fighting the kid he
goes that judge because uh Corey does a
uh coaching and cornering in Denver and
they were in I think like Colorado
Springs and one of his Fighters uh was
fighting and this judge just screwed his
fighter over so Corey goes up to him
after the fight in it they're you know
in the hall and they get into it bad bad
bad bad
bad bad and so that would equal that
because when Corey goes I got home I'm
looking at scoring like what the hell
and then he's like hold up how do I know
that guy looks I'd be like oh that's the
guy and he was like it was bad like I
mean he was like there's another thing
altercation but verbal shouting and like
Q's calling me like cuss words and he
was like it's bad they're all there are
all sorts of rules about conflicts of
interest which is why I will probably
never judge in Missouri because I know
too many people here I'm too connected
to gyms here like conflicts of interest
are a real important rule that people
need to follow and so never mind the
fact that he'd only judge three fights
he clearly should not have been judging
that fight so thank God Corey won last
last thing on on judging especially
refereeing in the NBA this just came out
was this NBA referee he grew up in
Boston his family's the biggest Boston
Celtics fans they looked into his data
because he got busted with a burner
account uh because when people would
roast like the calls they found there's
this one account like are you like
sticking up for him so they look into
it's him clearly dumbass but they look
more into it and he would do the NBA
Finals in the NBA uh playoffs and all
the Celtic games when he's the ref for
the Celtics they're 22-2
so they found out like and he grew up
you can't help it he grew up in Boston
his family lives breathes Boston Celtics
and there's there's this funny video
where they they like the guy makes a
three to win the game to beat the
Celtics and he goes oh like he's pissed
like during the game people like come on
Mike what are you doing bro he's all
[__] like hey what are you doing yeah so
it just goes to show you like like I
could never be a ref I have too many
friends I'm super biased I say that with
all my picks don't listen to me if the
guy hung out with the guy for a night
had some drinks same that's my guy same
don't listen to me on pics people like
yo you're so you're so off yeah I pick
all the guys I know every time yeah
every time 100 unless you're Charles
Oliver but I've never met him but if I
did I'd probably pick him more
well you're the best are you uh are you
working UFC uh 289 I am but I'll be I'll
be on the ESPN desk in Bristol so we're
doing the the post fight uh show on the
pre-show and UFC Live are in Bristol
Connecticut so that's where I will be
with Anthony Smith oh I love Anthony
tell him I said what's up and then any
news on uh the next time you're doing
the straight up commentating yeah July
is it first or second whatever Saturday
that is the very first Saturday in July
I've got that card next and then a few
more on the horizon yeah I love it
crushing it Superstar thank you you're
the best appreciate you thank you so
much